greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
April 15th
[ __ ] tax day [ __ ] but never
fear
uncle [ __ ] Joey's here you
understand me
this podcast is brought to you by my
favorite CBB company out there
CBD Lian calm listen picking a reliable
CBB company you don't know all the fiery
[ __ ] got gummies that [ __ ] liquor
store that you don't want to deal with
these people
lucky for you I found CBD Lian all right
now it comes into vapor cartridges and
chatter and a [ __ ] and if you're into
smoking if you're not into smoking you
can either gummy bear or do the teacher
like me to five thousand milligrams
under your tongue their products and
clean Bobby and they aren't like the
fakes that force with the false [ __ ]
advertising or whatnot so I'll tell you
what I'm gonna do go to CBD Lian calm
and check out their third party lab
results yourself the church family gets
twenty percent off at checkout when you
type in CH Urca Church that's CBD Lian
calm then I'm [ __ ] around go to the
box and pressed Church get twenty off
who the [ __ ] gives you that on tax day
number two whether you got a small
business big business a little business
hiring is always gonna be a challenge
but there's one place you could go
hiring is simple fast and smart a place
where growing businesses connect to
qualified candidates that place is zip
recruiter calm slash Church sip
recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful machine technology zip recruit
it scans thousands of resumes to find
the right people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job so do me a favor right now the
church family go to zip recruiter right
now I'm going to turn you on to zip
recruiter for free at this time well you
think you're dealing with it's a tax day
I'm gonna hook you up today right now
the listeners can try zip recruiter for
free gratis all right go to zipper
cooler comm slash Church that's zip
recruiter calm
slash Church zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire I'll tell you what else I'm
gonna drop on you guys today Robin Hood
you're like Joey what's Robin Hood who's
showing up nobody Robin Hood is an
investment app that lets you buy and
sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos or
Commission free all right
there's no account minimum deposit
needed to get started so you can start
investing at any level today Robin
Hood's
gonna teach you let's listen with Robin
Hood you can learn how to invest in the
market as you build your portfolio Robin
Hood is given the family the church
listeners are what happened now a free
stock like for an apple of Sprint to
help you build your portfolio sign up at
church dot Robin Hood combat that's
church dot Robin Hood calm learn and get
your life together with Robin Hood
dot-com Lee kick this [ __ ] meal
what's happened you bad [ __ ]
it's a whole new week with a whole new
set of rules and you're controlling the
[ __ ] ship this week don't give up you
understand maybe we had a [ __ ] up week
last week I had to be got a lot of [ __ ]
going on when I got off that plane from
[ __ ] Pittsburgh at 22,000 [ __ ]
panes connecting flights 40 minutes
[ __ ] rides to the airport
my liver heard I had a [ __ ]
temperature I had stress from [ __ ] I
had to take a stress test and I'm scared
of [ __ ] needles when you saw me here
Monday all cool and relaxed and Jennifer
Pryor I was [ __ ] [ __ ] pickles but
let me tell you about the week I had so
we'll go along as we [ __ ] and get to
it but number one I had to take the
stress test and every time I gotta get a
needle I [ __ ] my [ __ ] pants I [ __ ]
hate needles but I want anyway because
the doctor recommended I go the door and
the wife you know what's Lee gonna do
poor little [ __ ] kid I mean you know
so they care myself so much but some
doing okay you're all right
yeah you gotta control your green shirt
up t-shirt like you're in prison or some
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] am i dealing with it
anyway so I go to this [ __ ] trashed a
stress test stress test they send me in
you know I get the needle in the
get on guess what I don't think because
it got puts me upside down like I got 20
[ __ ] like the [ __ ] table
anyway Teeter Teeter I love it he puts
me upside down I don't faint then they
take a bunch of pictures of my heart
with my [ __ ] arms up you ever gonna
take [ __ ] you have to ever go from
Mirage pictures you have to sit still
that's when everything inches on my
[ __ ] body I gotta sit still I get it
just in places you never even [ __ ]
seen before crevasses up my ass this
thing zone my armpit my stink zone I
mean I [ __ ] had to sit there like a
mummy 20 minutes in this to take in the
back pull a little Filipino guy he's got
he like three weeks ago they put him to
work right away before the DREAM Act
expires he's in the bag [ __ ] speaking
Mexican and the next thing you know
another lady comes in and I got to do
the second phase which is shoot this
[ __ ] ink in your body then they put
you on a treadmill then they put you on
the [ __ ] back to the thing but it's
only 12 minutes and you're out of there
and I'll tell you what the last time I
did it oh my god when they shot the
income me it was like [ __ ] doing
heroin what I'm doing heroin yeah heart
pumps you know you start seeing little
[ __ ] spots I started sweating
profusely
I got nausea this time the dude told me
but just move your legs it's gonna shoot
into you for four minutes then for a
minute it's gonna do this I paired the
three minutes [ __ ] mark I can feel it
in my throat like my my throat was
starting to pop up but I kept kicking my
fat little [ __ ] legs and then I
thought they were gonna put me on the
treadmill you know I'm saying we got up
there for a few minutes but nothing
really happening I didn't get like the
last time I couldn't see they had a
window so I didn't get no anxiety I was
in [ __ ] shock and then I went back
and did the 12 more minutes and pictures
and I was out and it was like a [ __ ]
rock falling off my butt when I was dead
lady goes listen you're breathing weird
something's wrong with you I don't know
Anderson I got more dilemmas not my
head's racing now for three nights I
haven't slept because of this [ __ ]
needle now I got to deal with and the
doctor couldn't see me that day so I had
to go back the next day and what I had
was like a [ __ ] light pneumonia like
he [ __ ] threw some antibodies and me
that were it's a [ __ ] you take ten days
before you go to the jungle antibiotic
that's what
that that whilst Roman is like a feeling
I tried to work out for two days
it was raffia yeah but you know what we
got a pretty keep pushing the good news
is listen for the next three and a half
weeks I'm gonna go [ __ ] between New
York and here and Texas to shoot two
different [ __ ] movies so I'll be back
and forth now when you listen to her
podcast these are all have been
pre-taped this month they're gonna be
pre taped to the end of the month I'm
not gonna tell you what the [ __ ] is
gonna be our table didn't get on last
week was Alex Jones and saying my
deepest apologies we had done the second
podcast that day and he was running late
and head he was running late so you know
what we I was [ __ ] I was seeing spots
on Wednesday when I first learn at the
antibiotics that you know the first
podcast was long enough I had to cancel
my spots at the store Thursday night
that's how bad I thought I had green
[ __ ] coming out of my nose and mouth but
had never seen before when we finished a
podcast on Wednesday I was driving home
and I couldn't breathe I had a green
[ __ ] snot my nose that was green like
Lee's [ __ ] sure it was disgusting and
I couldn't find a [ __ ] napkin I had a
driver
I couldn't even fling it off my [ __ ]
thing that was so disgusting usually I
eat those things like like it's a lot
d'oeuvre and a [ __ ] nice little white
party but this discussion could even
[ __ ] eat it that's how much [ __ ] I
had in me so you know what man I'm
taking it easy I start shooting this
movie Tuesday maybe a couple days and I
come back then I'm off to Minneapolis
this [ __ ] weekend that's sold out
then four [ __ ] 20
we're in Milwaukee that's to take this
couple tickets left for each show so see
what you got left and put it together
but that's not the main thing I want to
talk to you guys about lately I've been
getting a lot of hits like what happened
to this and what happened to that listen
guys let me tell you what's going on
with us you know what man since I was a
kid I've always liked to evolve
there's always something you could do to
better yourself always if you're honest
with yourself there's always something
you could do like there's always [ __ ] to
cut back on or you know what man I have
anything you ever get on the scale and
you're 22 pounds heavier and you know
I'm not eating it and also you think
about what you've been eating lately
like [ __ ] all those [ __ ] shakes do it
up I'm gonna [ __ ] 18 no more I can
have two milkshakes a day from Carvel
and dip the ID you can't do that [ __ ]
all your life you know so every couple
months you have to look at what you got
and reevaluate and see what's going on
let me tell you some of the last two
years my house has changed so last year
basically the homeless chance again
they changed when I got the kid in then
it changed again when she went to pre-k
then when she got to kindergarten it
really [ __ ] chance
like you know every day at 4 o'clock my
day ends whatever the [ __ ] I'm doing
unless I'm getting a [ __ ] envelope my
day ends cuz I gotta go pick her up and
then you got martial art classes you got
swimming you got gymnastics you know it
never [ __ ] ends and you have a kid
people at home littlest them know that
it never ends when you have a kid but it
also carried over to the podcast like
looks at men from time to time I'm up at
night late I can't sleep I have insomnia
and I'll listen to an old podcast and
yeah I'll get a laugh out of the podcast
but I'll see a lot of dull spots in that
you know and I'm like you know what man
I gotta clean up
alright there you know we've been doing
this podcast for six seven years and
we're very fortunate if you noticed this
before switch podcast 18 times and seven
years I wanted to prove a point when I
start this podcast early that we don't
quit you know I'm saying no matter rain
snow shine this is what you do you you
give them something when you tell them
you're gonna give them something so
listen if I didn't give a [ __ ] about
this podcast I could just come down here
and tour Chile and do edibles and you
know what eventually you'll think it's
cute and you'll move the [ __ ] on well
guess what I'd moved the [ __ ] on too
because nothing's going on so I don't
know for the last year I just noticed we
was having a hard time one night we're
here doing bong hits and this poor
bastard cost and I seen blood on his
[ __ ] hands at that point you got to
start thinking about what the [ __ ]
with your wife this poor kid gets
bronchitis every 90 days he's not used
to this [ __ ] listen I'm showing up with
weed here you guys think we're [ __ ]
with you like I go to certain weed
stores because they give me this dirty
1% 30% weed they know what I like the
owners know I give them [ __ ] love so
they saved me the best of what they can
get even if they don't carry
store they gotta say give me an answer
Joey and I just put that [ __ ]
away that's what I do we smoke some
strong [ __ ] leads it and I've seen
you know my god I'm at home doing 20 of
these bong hits all [ __ ] day six in
the morning five at two o'clock another
six at night I do two of them what Lee
and I see where the poor kid is so I'm
[ __ ] killing myself to live right
after I shot the Netflix special there
was a lot of things I had to cut up but
prior to Netflix special I had already
slowed down with the animals because I
had something going on my body I
couldn't put my [ __ ] finger on it
some type of something was just
bothering me would hum in my head from
time to time so I had to start getting
rid of stuff I got rid of milk I got rid
of [ __ ] eating cheese I got rid of
[ __ ] you know I just cut things down
that you know whey protein I cut all the
stuff down that I thought was affecting
me and you know what the edibles man
there are a lot of fun that the Lord
knows we ate twenty-nine thousand
million milligrams in four or five years
it didn't stop him here but if you want
to evolve you know what if I want to
give you a better podcast and I want you
guys to have a better experience yeah
from time to time we have the right
guest we'd get high in exam but if not
let's do the podcast [ __ ] straight
let's try doing the podcast rate I
couldn't do the [ __ ] uh what's the
thing I was doing with the free thing
but more enjoy the morning join ortho
again
listen I don't know if I told you guys
one day I went to pre-k to pick her up
and like that name I'm my wife pulled me
over but she's like you can't get high
and going there no more I guess you want
and then on one you smell like a pot
Forester kids passed out after you left
the [ __ ] building or something I
don't know what the [ __ ] so you know
what man when it comes to us [ __ ]
around I can [ __ ] around I got time to
[ __ ] around when it comes to my daughter
listen men don't have a chance to make
mistakes women and [ __ ] kids do we
don't have chance to make mistakes so I
couldn't go back to that school stone so
I I can't get I can't smoke 20 bong hits
in the morning and dry with a [ __ ]
school and let those people see me like
that or go to kickboxing at night
I just couldn't do it no more I could do
a bong attitude don't get me wrong I
love my marijuana Oh ain't nobody
[ __ ] quitting here the last three
days I haven't even smoked pot and it's
because I had this this chest of my cold
and I do not want to travel with this
chest of Michael this this cold in my
chest this is how the downhill started
for Ralphie was with a pneumonia if
nobody remembers about three four years
ago they put him in the hospital for
four weeks in Florida
you could even visit the poor bastard
because he was in a [ __ ] hospital
because his lungs couldn't take him home
Ralphie would go from city to city and
he was such a sweetheart of a guy that
he would smoke with everybody and when
you're when you're going on one city a
month and coming back and smoke and
that's one thing but when you're going
to four [ __ ] cities in a month and
you're still open for different types of
viral flus with people you're eventually
gonna get sick and he got sicker and
sicker then he got a [ __ ] cold that
would not leave him a coughs that it was
just horrible but he had for about six
months and next thing you know he goes
on a [ __ ] cruise ship or something
and they gotta take him off the cruise
ship I feel bad for those guys that had
carry him on those skinny [ __ ] steps
they had to [ __ ] put metal on those
steps they had to get him off on one of
those beds he [ __ ] with a they four guys
got ahold each side like that
this guy found life yeah like a
stretcher only he told me was never so
embarrassed in his life it's when you
can't breathe it's terrible it's
terrible and I went through it's Sunday
night this week I came home I'm not
kidding you guys I don't complain about
being [ __ ] sick my liver [ __ ] hurt
and there's nothing wrong with
Pittsburgh Pittsburgh was phenomenal but
now I didn't have the best sets in my
life I didn't have the sets I wanted and
looking back I was sick I could just it
was crazy how sick I was when I go to a
town and I don't work out one time like
I was gonna last out in Pittsburgh I
couldn't do it I couldn't even [ __ ]
move the next day I would eat breakfast
and have to go right back to bed and
then bring theraflu at me a lemming
vitamin C with me I thought I had
theraflu but I must have thought he
drank them the last time I was sick
a couple of years ago listen men you
know I'm at a different age than you
guys I can't afford to get sick right
now I can't have a six-month [ __ ]
layoff I like going out too much I can't
enjoy going out and doing comedy twice a
month
it's my release last night I went out
for the first time all [ __ ] week I
didn't I need you over the hill in
Laurel Canyon
you stay home every [ __ ] night with
your wife and you 5 o'clock 4 o'clock me
afternoon on you'll lose your [ __ ]
mind
now I know why guys [ __ ] snap and it
it's nothing about not loving them or
not wanna be around them it's that you
have your your [ __ ] moments you have
to get out of the house to do what you
do I went to the Konami store was like a
grenade went off I want [ __ ] bananas
down there cuz I was like in jail all
[ __ ] week and I went home and it was
a release and now tomorrow I gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here to start shooting
on Tuesday this morning I got up with
the girls and I went into my office and
mercy came in and she was petting one of
the cats and she next thing you know she
cuddled over on my leg and I kept typing
on the computer and I looked over to
pick her up and she was crying and she
doesn't know how long I'm gonna come
back well humming I think I'm coming
back East to [ __ ] Sunday or a little
before that no I can't cuz I'll be in
Minneapolis but they said that maybe I'd
come home on Wednesday so Wednesday I'll
come back chill for a few days go to
Minneapolis right from here with Dean
Dell Rizzi and then do 420 up and
[ __ ] Milwaukee and then go back to
New York on Easter Sunday so it's either
or I don't have what my schedule is but
like I told you guys you're covered we
shot putt we tape podcast so they can
extend all the way through May 4th
anyway back to the evolution of [ __ ]
life and what you gotta do every couple
months so a couple weeks ago you know on
how to be like seven weeks ago I just
solely kept getting sick you know it's
too much drama every time we came in
here we smoked we got away for [ __ ]
lead and get it together
six minutes his eyes would get pinned on
the top of his head sometimes and he
does a bong hit he sucks it and his eyes
go up I think he's dying half the time
listen I like the kid I don't want no
problems I don't love to carry him out
of here ambience an ambulance or
stretcher
we've got enough we don't have to prove
ourselves to any
buddy we didn't laughing yeah we still
get high I know he was looking for
edibles dear man but see you'll have to
get your license back and go to the
store and I'll send you right to her
bourbon trees not to tell you what I'm
gonna get okay no I got some [ __ ]
gummy bears to the ten milligrams apiece
you know yesterday I went to shin-soo
you Shin Eun with the daughter and I
popped 20 milligrams and I gotta tell
you I was [ __ ] stoned oh yeah you
don't get high for seven eight hours no
more I'm twenty milligrams it's like a
two three hour high but at least I know
they're getting me high Jesus Christ
we're eating mm it took me six months to
[ __ ] out all the [ __ ] jello powder
and and [ __ ] that those things had in
your system you know what those things
clog to your [ __ ] system now you
wonder why brand [ __ ] muffins and
drink kombucha every day and eat yogurt
as much as I can what banana isn't
[ __ ] a little bit of granola because
you gotta balance out your stomach you
got to put those [ __ ]
those things back in your [ __ ]
stomach I'm not you you can't [ __ ] you
you you all backed up for [ __ ] weeks
so you gotta take care yourself and I
just figured that Jesus Christ you know
we've done the podcast all this time why
not give it a breathing and you're gonna
see the quality of the podcast it's not
a longer podcast no more cuz when I
forget my topics were rambling today
it's a [ __ ] shorter more concise get
to the point let's wrap it the [ __ ] up I
know you people unless the other night
on the podcast type I just want you to
maintain uncle join your life and don't
get rid of me listen we got our ups and
we got our downs just like anything else
in life the podcast business like
anything else that's why I tell people
the hardest thing you could do is like
late night TV you gotta be twenty five
nights so we guess what that's not gonna
happen every day
that's not you're not gonna have a great
show five nights a week but as long as
you're going there give it your all and
you show up and you know it you're in
then you try to give the people
something [ __ ] different don't [ __ ]
work with you let me tell you something
not only my upset about I'm not upset
about this movie and the other movie in
Texas I'm not upset at all I'm upset
that I have to leave my family for four
weeks five week
I'm shooting both of these movie
starting my Tuesday the 16th and I'll be
shooting till the 17th of [ __ ] May
calling back and forth between Texas New
York and for the [ __ ] Los Angeles
yeah I'll get to see them but you know
what I'm used to seeing them five
[ __ ] days a week so but again you
know what man even a 56 you gotta learn
how to get out of your comfort zone time
to time I got places to go work out when
I'm in Texas I got places to go works
out when I'm in New York I got friends
in New York
I got friends in Texas so both places
and I'm not doing any comedy I'm just
focusing on the movies that's why I had
a reschedule San Antonio in Dallas which
got rescheduled now the 8th and the 9th
of September I don't know what city but
I'm gonna put them on my website before
I [ __ ] start traveling we scheduled
the dates are in and then November 7th
I'm at the Motor City casino in Detroit
so everything is great for you guys got
a my little concert thing so I busted
you guys balls about to make jagged
documentary okay good final but when I
saw it I figured out that yes I want to
get back into the concert scene or just
get out to be entertained yes they will
know my daughter my wife Tish in you I
forgot what it was to be entertained and
the only way you can entertain is by
getting entertained and you guys know
nothing flux my [ __ ] boat I don't
give a [ __ ] about after shows on TV but
you know what floats my boat it's just
day one something live I've always
enjoyed live music or people jumping up
and down or some people playing congas
in a in a park I've always been
mesmerized by that like I'm not when
you're doing the conga line with a bunch
of filthy [ __ ] hippies and something
I know I don't like that [ __ ] I'm
talking about music I'm Central Park or
I like live performances I even like
live dance like I don't mind watching
live dance an expression of art you
could make your body do [ __ ] I don't
even dream adorable I want to show you
yesterday those women those Chinese
really shuffle their feet fascinating
but I never seen in my life those little
[ __ ] Chinese feet could move
they were gone from North the wet south
to north they were flying into the
[ __ ] screen those Japanese were I
don't know what they are Chinese John it
doesn't matter there was some white
people on the [ __ ] cast it was a
great [ __ ] show listen well I have
gone a mile and not in a million [ __ ]
years and never do I want to sit in a
Saturday afternoon was the [ __ ]
theater what a bunch of people you know
I gotta tell you something it was
[ __ ] cool as [ __ ] and I know my
daughter enjoy did we stay after the
intermission [ __ ] no my daughter
couldn't take another hour that [ __ ]
jumping up and down she thought there
was gonna be some kung fu people get
some knife throwing new drugs and [ __ ]
after like the first time I thought look
at the me she's like it's time to go
when they gave us intermission cuz she
kept wobbling around her seat so I'm
like maybe she got a piercing on a piece
she goes no Laura no it's just about to
ask me you gotta go you want to take a
walk you feel like they kind of walking
me white dude came out this is the last
dance and after that we're gonna have a
15-minute intermission so we sat we
watched the last [ __ ] dance
and I told my wife and Darla got if you
gotta go to the bathroom go I had a pee
but I wanted them to get going get back
and then when they got back the game my
ticket I went to the bathroom when I
wasn't walking out of the bathroom but I
washed my hands my phone's ringing it's
my wife she cuz they immerse you don't
want to stay I went back home - you want
you on the stage because I'm done I'm
good I saw all I need to see it's
definitely your daughter definitely my
daughter I looked at her I know my wife
so I'm not even mad I don't know and we
got our little [ __ ] no but we put the
car season and we zoomed right back to
the [ __ ] house but you know what one
thing about the last I've known about
this movie and all this stuff for the
last three or four weeks I spent as much
time as I could with them you know even
when I don't have movies or anything
planned I try to spend as much time as I
can with those girls it's it's sickening
like I don't have a [ __ ] social life
I don't see you anymore other than the
podcast really in common I'm not [ __ ]
doing comedy
and I'm not podcasting I'm not working
out I'm pretty much at the girls I'm
pretty much with one of them or both of
them
are doing something it's just really
insane how much my life has changed man
I've been my wife we're gonna go on a
20th anniversary Wow this year right
yeah 20th anniversary I think next year
this is 19 years married or just
together together that's awesome
I'll tell you it's you'd think that will
your marriage things will go in the
opposite directions no I gotta tell you
something it's gotten better you know
and who knows it makes a marriage work
the first time I couldn't make it work
if I was in Sin City I was a [ __ ]
loser and a half I think because I had
the divorce and I saw what things
externally and internally I lost from it
if I got married I was prepared for a
long haul it's like we talked about with
Tommy like in 90 I got on stage in 91
but in 93 I realized what I had to do to
make the [ __ ] haul this is what needs
to be done you need to do this I know
you don't like this but you better get
ready for it is you're gonna have to do
it and I prepared myself for all these
things I didn't want to do that now I
had to do because I knew it was part of
the path to get to the goal I wanted to
reach I never wanted to get to this goal
right now this goal was never even
thought of it was just a goal of
survival being able to travel from week
to week to different places
people to stay off the radar but you
know what hard work brings a result and
that's why we're here and that's why
were in this room doing this [ __ ]
podcast so you never know until you
[ __ ] get down a path but it's so
weird in the eighties I saw the
scorpions and then I think me and Perry
vege and a bunch other guys saw a small
shank Natur and 83 or 82 or any one I
don't remember what anymore I don't wait
and they go see [ __ ] Michael Shanklin
and I think in January Dean bell rang
and uh Danny from the Comedy Store the
sound guy in the main room sweetheart of
a guy who can unknown how long I've been
at the Comedy Store I said to me that
Michael Schenker was coming with Michael
Schenker was one of the original
guitarist of the scorpions and this him
and his brother and then he went off
he's a [ __ ] wild man and then his own
stuff the MSG group and all his stuff
and they told me that [ __ ] April 15th
16th and 17th he was doing three nights
at one of the clubs in town you know
whisky a go-go on the Troubadour I think
it's a whiskey I was blown the [ __ ] away
finally I wasn't gonna see a [ __ ]
live band only the Tuesday I was I think
we picked Tuesday like that who wouldn't
have a podcast we could just go down and
then when the band is finished we've
gone on The Comedy Store for Tuesday
that was the plan and all sudden I get
this [ __ ] movies and I can't do now
listen I'll tell you what was I
depressed at yeah I'm [ __ ] depressed
I was looking forward to it
I was hoping with him to call me and
said they'd switch my shooting date to
the 18th or the 17th Wednesday
definitely I go see Michael Shanklin
tomorrow and I but things didn't work
out and sometimes you gotta sacrifice
just to [ __ ] one one of my 10 I'm
gonna knock do something cuz I gotta go
see I gotta be that Tuesday ready to go
I figured I'd get in there tomorrow at
2:00 in the afternoon I gotta go to
wardrobe I'll get a nice light [ __ ]
dinner and then go to the room maybe
smoke a number and just go to bed and
[ __ ] get up and work that's that's it
it's cool it's been it's been a few
years since you did a movie you know man
when I got here they were shooting more
movies with me there were different
types of movies I don't get those calls
anymore and I can't lie to you I do I
still get calls for a ton of [ __ ]
[ __ ] the problem is again with the
podcast and the family and if it's a
gamble if I'm doing something for money
but I really don't like the sides or
something like that guess what I'd
rather not do it I have always known
that when it comes to acting like when I
first got here yeah well
auditions and I made my mistakes but
then once I started booking I got the
hang of it and then after a while
something else happens you start getting
cocky
you stood cherry-picking but I cherry
picked with backing like with science
like before I would cherry-pick a role I
would think of it from all directions
like what is this role gonna do for me
three years like the a day somebody put
up a short film when I play the science
cooking teacher Louie the teach yourself
like that these are all the movies I was
doing after the writers strike
they were $100 a day movies you got to
bring your own [ __ ] clothes you got
to shoot an odd [ __ ] hours because
they don't have enough money to shoot it
to place and at the end of the day they
just [ __ ] practice on acting because
man attend don't go anyway
I'll tell you this with all my heart
yeah there was a movie years ago that
made somebody to check from the Clint
Eastwood movie but she was a boxer oh uh
yeah she did a hundred our name really
and it blew up some movie star baby yeah
the girl from Million Dollar Baby
right before Million Dollar Baby did a
hundred hours a day movie and the
[ __ ] thing blew up so people were
like pushing for holiday movies and I
pay the [ __ ] I pay sag and I pay sag
a lot of money even though I don't do
dick like I don't do dick compared to
what I used to do so the sag you gotta
pay them like twice a year and at the
end of the year they add up what you're
made and you getting a percentage of
that so on the only reason why I'm still
I mean listen I'm very proud that I'm
gonna get a [ __ ] pension and I've
been acting for 20 [ __ ] years now in
this town but with the same token the
values went down on what they're paying
you I mean by 50 percent
there's actors leave in this town every
day on the daily and I'm not trying to
sound negative I'm just being honest
with you there are actors leaving this
town every day because the roles are
just not animal when you figure with
Netflix and
six other channels on TV and all these
who moves and everything I don't even
know anybody who goes into that you guys
know from Michael Rapaport that tutorial
the 20 other actors I speak to we're not
great friends but I speak to from time
to time and say hello and check in with
not too many of them set in the world on
fire they're not setting the world on
fire like they you stun again you go on
age groups here it's like 18 to 22 and
then 22 to 27 then 27 to 32 then 36 to
40 to 40 or 45 then 45 to 55 and they
put you in a different category so the
older you are though the more the
percentage the less the percentage of
you going honest you know so I was
cherry-picking for a long time you're
gonna send me an audition and I know
what the Edition [ __ ] entails right
in my head I do the math you're not
gonna shoot Hollywood it's this you know
what I make more money by not doing a
job because at the end of the week I
gotta pay two Commission's and taxes and
then you look at what's left over and
you go for that I got a drive to Marina
del Rey three days in traffic and
whatnot it's not worth the aggravation
well you opened up the podcast saying
that you have to evolve and we you've
spoken about it when you first moved
here you started acting as a way to work
and to get in and to for free involve
your comedy I did then you don't need a
name I did 20 [ __ ] movies that you'll
never see my dream is saying you know I
did I used to do college films that's
how I call it experience by doing
college films I never stopped I just
kept doing College films every time I
had a chance I'd do more more College
films and eventually have popped out of
that I did that for about a year and a
half and then I got into the commercial
business for a while that was great
that's a look at their business and then
I got into a real real real theatrical
of it and I booked bass ketball when I
booked the one when I moved to I already
had a pilot and then it was slow for two
years I really focused on my comedy it
made me mainly want 2001-2002
once I went with MADtv I was off and
running and that lasted to 2007 and then
the strike came and right away I got
coming to one of the strike happened I
was on Greg Garcia's call our show
my name is our name is Earl and he would
give me episodes I mean he just at that
point he would just called me at 2:30
for a 4:30 shoot to get there
to the valley at 4:30 so I had friends
just giving me roles but it just went
down the pipe and they just went down
the tubes the interesting was thing was
that when I signed with Justin the guy
who books me comedic Lee didn't have a
theatrical department and my agent
wasn't doing a good job
and I would still get these little
office for youtube series that didn't
pay dick you know didn't pay dick I
looked at the director there wasn't
nobody know worthy to work with you know
like is he gonna lift my career up is he
gonna bring something different to the
table and I started saying the word know
which dropped a month you'll hear a
couple actors that came on in comics and
then oh you know tell you that sometimes
it's okay to say no if you don't feel
like this is gonna get you to where you
want to be it's okay to [ __ ] say no
and from time to time I started saying
no but the last three or four years I
keep getting these things that are legit
offers they're just undoable either
undoable because the script sucks or
undoable because i can't get there it's
two planes to get there and it's gonna
it's a one-day shoot but it's three days
of my time and I have enough to cancel
to podcast and then right from there I
gotta go to a road gig and you know what
like I said I'm getting old I can't
handle a [ __ ] no more so I've been
cherry-picking but I told my agent about
six months ago he keeps he kept saying I
mean look at you getting these offers
and they're just not whatever do you
feel bad like oh no I'm a guy at the
plate sometimes you gotta wait for a
[ __ ] fastball they're gonna throw
curve balls at you they're gonna throw
knuckle balls at you throw balls at you
but if you're patient and you know
they're gonna throw you a [ __ ]
fastball and you know I got a lot of
office for voiceover which which I've
been doing a lot more lately I've done
like three or four voiceovers this year
I started of the year by doing the the
Theo von pilot and the Danny Brown pilot
from vice I did another pilot from the
dear friend of mine so you know what I
had a good little [ __ ] year going and
next thing you know I got this offer on
this movie which I signed the
confidentiality agreement so I can't
really speak about them till they let me
sign off on it and this movie's gonna be
dynamic it's gonna be [ __ ] tremendous
something I got a nice little roll in it
it comes out next jiangshi at Racal
release I'm gonna try to get the book to
come out around that time I'm gonna try
to get I love a CD at around that time
you know just to highlight the movie
from a professional way like in the old
days when you hit you hit with three or
four things it's not just a [ __ ]
overhead right you got him on an
overhead right two body shots and we
come back to the top on a left [ __ ]
jab or something sleepy used a soda
what's that the three pieces a soda
the three piece in the soda that
[ __ ] gonna be all right I'm
leaving town
and he's coming in [ __ ] George Mazda
bye I hope we hit Tuesday I think Dylan
Rogen's podcast so that's the way it
works also I had Danny Brown in town the
last two days we couldn't get him on the
podcast so Finn isn't one thing it's the
other it's been one of those weeks and
again my apologies to Howard Jones I
couldn't tell him on the phone I had the
flu and I felt I'm the type of guy when
I'm sick man I don't want people around
if I can't buy you I don't really want
you around that tell you why cuz you're
gonna get it you're gonna get it you
know I got it if I got this flu let me
they are strong this fluids you ready
for this I got a kid in the in
kindergarten every time you walk in the
kindergarten it smells like death in
there
it smells like [ __ ] death in
kindergarten you could tell the flu is
floating around the [ __ ] ham every
time I wore every time my daughter comes
home and I hug her I love her to death
but she smells [ __ ] horrible
the crease in her head with her [ __ ]
with a part in the head with her higher
little parts
smells horrible it's as if my daughter
not really it's all the kids she comes
in contact with all [ __ ] that and
they all have something so my immune
systems been built the [ __ ] up for the
last couple years because of having a
child I already had the flus I was gonna
get from her already now it's just
that's how bad this flu footage flew to
take me out for two weeks how it did cuz
the first week it really wasn't a flu I
just didn't feel like me I had a
headache every [ __ ] day you got that
thing in your throat what are you
thinking gonna get second two days but
it really doesn't deliver she's spitting
mild colors but nothing really serious
you know I'm saying like every three
spits is like a little [ __ ] yellow
maybe a little piece of blood are you
spitting you know you gotta spit when
you take a lot of water when you work
out you're [ __ ] sick but last week
when I was in Pittsburgh when I didn't
even feel like working out I already had
the body aches once those body aches at
you that's when it's [ __ ] real and
the temperature broke I think Wednesday
night I went to bed and I took my shirt
off like a savage and the fan was
blowing on me I said [ __ ] it
I put the [ __ ] covers over my head
and I could ride out right there I could
feel when I woke up the next morning it
was just a puddle of [ __ ] drenched
under me so the the temperature broke
after two and antibiotics and there's
that still had to cancel store story's
not this stuff right I got a little
better yesterday a little better today
with the grace of God I'm ready for
Monday the [ __ ] 15th yeah I
still got half tomorrow antibiotics to
eat but who gives the [ __ ] another plane
ride tomorrow I'm definitely putting one
of those Japanese masks on the plane
yeah I want them bought 20 of them I
can't deal no more listen these planes
are filthy especially now that the 737
and went down now that putting more
people more [ __ ] planes and you're
gonna do a bow oh I'm doing the whole
thing like when I was over at the
University of Colorado when I was faking
the funk oh yeah Tom Segura podcast this
week you're missing out on [ __ ] life
you understand me listen I'm in a
constant decision when I came back from
the Netflix shoot but I'm not [ __ ]
around No
I only go to the comedy store just so
I'm high I'm on high alert at all
[ __ ] times you understand me I'm on
high alert at all times Lia tight only
will tell you I'm on high alert at all
times 7:00 in the morning I'm gonna call
I'm striving for the [ __ ] funny now
oh and it's the truth and that's just as
bad as it is I don't know what I got
left on this planet and I don't know how
much I got left on this [ __ ]
strangeness but from now on every time I
go on that stage I'm giving you
everything I have [ __ ] god the same
thing with podcast I love you people
contact me and you'd be on my pod
Colette number one I don't know you I'm
not walking into a [ __ ] nest of death
no what the [ __ ] you got number two I
don't do that many podcast and there's a
reason for that one I just don't have
the time and two there's no reason to
delay the [ __ ] podcast a month
because I'd rather go on a podcast and
kill it then go on three podcasts and be
mediocre that's my philosophy listen we
do a podcast here alone
I don't a podcast two of them a
sensational for them a passable and two
of them you want to shoot yourself after
twenty five [ __ ] minutes and I
understand that that's the law of
diminishing returns but since we stopped
smoking reefer they're gonna get better
every month I'm gonna do better
interviews you know hopefully we'll keep
the [ __ ] camera where it's supposed
to be looking at me directly with a
little box I want you people to feel me
constantly on a constant level and I
also want you to feel the guests on a
constant level that's why I don't like
the wide shots a little more between
three people it's either me him or the
cameras only cuz he's [ __ ] talk these
are all these things and prove a podcast
is what we've been working on the last
couple months like I said they're not
all gonna be Academy of wood one is let
me see it direct though you know James
cannon went from arrow to [ __ ] zero
he's thrown [ __ ] dust at you but
James Cameron also did that [ __ ]
movie end of all what is it avatar
avatar head The Vow I don't [ __ ] know
it's closed for you avatar he also had
80 million dollars to work we don't have
80 million dollars to work a little bit
of [ __ ] budget yeah we got what the
[ __ ] we got all right we're not part of
a network
when I Paulino communism [ __ ] shower
here this is just us giving your love
every [ __ ] couple days and throwing
some [ __ ] he just let you know what
the [ __ ] were thinking here on a
beautiful Monday April [ __ ]
15th tip-top Magoo you got your health
you got your family so what you ate a
couple [ __ ] down pills last week who
gives a [ __ ] it's a whole new [ __ ]
week you know I'm saying just don't eat
[ __ ] pills just smoke a little reefer
relax get your life together these whole
new [ __ ] way that's why I love
mondays that's why when I travel this
and you couldn't [ __ ] pay me to stain
your [ __ ] down on a Sunday I don't
give a [ __ ] if you show up in a thousand
[ __ ] [ __ ] chicks to suck dick then
you kill them afterwards so they don't
tell nobody and everyone witnesses no I
don't I don't know I like to come home
eat the Lord's Day dinner with my family
and then Monday by the time Monday
morning comes I'm [ __ ] rested and I'm
ready to take the [ __ ] week down like
Isis you understand me I'm ready just
died
what the [ __ ] are you laughing about
there at least I think they're nice yeah
no [ __ ] nice I'm just telling you
[ __ ] the truth how I feel and
what we're gonna get going for you from
now [ __ ] on you understand me don't
forget you got your [ __ ] you got your
[ __ ] 4/20 show in no Waukee
Wisconsin at the Pops Tina me and my man
Dean Dell Rizzi he was in Detroit last
week and kill them like Mark Ridley's
comedy Castle and [ __ ] Royal Oak
Michigan a little suburb outside Detroit
I used to visit years ago they didn't
like me Rollo
they looked at me 20 years ago like I
had problems that's why I only went
there one and done jack I was like
whatever that coaches what he do with
those people he won an Calipari yeah I
was one and [ __ ] done when I went to
Detroit but listen I gave it a shot that
was a long time ago I'm a different
timing today and that's all that matters
man but listen things could be a lot
worse you know we're doing our job on
the podcast we got these [ __ ] little
movies Leah's doing stand-up you know
he's trying his best to get it together
and we're healthy and that's all you can
[ __ ] pray for in one week
I mean now we come on here what you know
a couple times a week you listen to your
[ __ ] level room summary is Letterman
let us into your [ __ ] hearts I get
the messages I read them and I'm very
appreciative you guys have you listened
to cigar I want a little [ __ ] it off on
there but again if you know me you know
I don't [ __ ] name them this thing I
just talk like that just a [ __ ]
because it's the truth
without [ __ ] it's the truth I don't
mean it but if the truth I don't mean
it's the [ __ ] truth
you know those kids those those parents
putting their kids through college and
paying off all that [ __ ] money who
does it hurt there it's [ __ ] minority
kids I mean I didn't say like that paint
that's true picture for you so you see
what the [ __ ] is going on here
so there's no misunderstandings you
understand I feel you but no I really
appreciate you guys sticking out with us
like I said the next three two weeks
they're gonna wall but I got great guest
we got great guest great surprises I'm
not gonna give you no [ __ ] names we
got a great lineup for you so just keep
listening and hang in there with us and
that's that [ __ ] I see them
saying at least we're moving ahead
whether it's hokey spooky or my bad Bob
low Lingus we'll move on ahead
we got rid of the deadweight and it's
onward and [ __ ] onward you understand
we got a great [ __ ] year coming I'm
gonna rest the rest of the month once I
come back from these movies I'm gonna be
tired so I'm gonna chill at home for two
weeks and then we got a great [ __ ]
schedule or summer we start with
[ __ ] New Orleans and Atlanta at
the Tabernacle [ __ ] theater right in
June and then we're taking it to
[ __ ] Columbus your boy what's
his name Steve Simone
Oh from the fam what's his name in the
front cast a good times got a good time
the family one hour podcast Hartman's
pg-rated
it's like watch the Dick Van Dyke
episode he's coming with me cuz he's
restarting the podcast yeah we're doing
this week I think he said he's gonna
start up on Tuesday it was a very
interesting that last I had accomplished
aw man I saw Simone I saw a Rick Rehn
mostly I saw Jason what's his last Lucas
Lucas and those guys are the Three
Stooges 20 is yeah they were all three
doormen
looking for that [ __ ] way you know
Jason Lucas is a [ __ ] editor now and
God knows who Ric Ramos does he's just
[ __ ] watching movies and talking [ __ ]
about him I love him to death
he was talking to my movies last name is
interesting his [ __ ] we gotta get him
back home when I come back and Steve
Simone it is so weird I was talking to
Jason Lucas and I told the story all
over the podcast we taped last week but
you guys'll be listening to how long
I've known Jason [ __ ] Lucas I met
Jacob Laysan Lucas and I was a feature
act at the comedy cabana and Myrtle
Beach South Carolina
he was the opening act and he kept
talking to me about the Comi store where
the things true I told him yes and he
[ __ ] he said he would be coming up
would I help him out if he came up like
oh you know I'm just uh I'm just getting
peed on myself over there but I'll do
whatever I can to help you you know uh
whatever I could do all [ __ ] help me
you know at that time I had no pole I
didn't know anybody stolen time he
pulled over the [ __ ] run in that joint
I keep out of that [ __ ] it makes my
longevity there longer and when that I
started coming up to the store and you
know what he started paying at first he
would pay everything and come to the
store and sit in the back and watch it
keep his mouth shut and then they
started letting him for free and I'd see
him back there from time to time and
that will then follow Mooney and he give
me some notes his [ __ ] I'd look at him
like this kids crazy comes here three
four nights a week to watch I know I'm
just gonna [ __ ] doorman job here
and that's exactly what he did he's got
a dog died job upped and he was up there
a night watching watching watching and
when he got his shot he [ __ ] became a
regular and you know what you know with
all the changings or the government's up
there within that [ __ ] mu ties with
the [ __ ] up act when he got caught
stealing
you know Jason Lucas got caught like
nobody really know who he was but he
kept going up and he kept fighting for
him believing you know what the talent
coordinator had him believe them he
started giving him late-night spots late
night spots late night spots late night
spots and last night he went up before
me he said he got an early spot and guys
it's listen I'm not here blowing smoke
up your ass it that that story applies
to anything that you do it whether it's
carpentry an artist you just hang in
there you know what he was lost in the
[ __ ] wind there for an hour and he's
still hung in there and he still goes
down and now instead of getting spots at
1:00 in the morning 12:30 which he's got
three kids he's gotta go to work and
he's got a regular [ __ ] day job as
never he hangs out back there does he
complain does he say anything no he goes
down there he does his spot at 12:30
did he ask anybody to get him spots that
he asked anybody to get him early spots
he didn't say dick he just kept going
down at one o'clock and last night he
got like a nine o'clock [ __ ] spot
8:45 guess what when I get back yeah I'm
gonna have him on the podcast just so he
could tell you the story I respect that
and [ __ ] man I respect when somebody
just hangs in there just keeping maccha
keep your [ __ ] mouth shut
put your head down and know that no good
deed goes undone like no just keep keep
[ __ ] doing what you don't shut your
mouth nobody asked you for your opinion
that's for starters nobody asked you for
your opinion the more I was watching the
n-c-double-a finals and when I was
watching both teams last week they did
not put the ball down on the floor
that's his discipline as can be when
you're talking about basketball when you
turn basketball into just a passing game
and do that wasted dribble the same
thing applies to life the more you
[ __ ] dribble you're gonna get
yourself into trouble when you're up
there when you're going for yours but
for specific thing then I'm gonna give
it to you nobody's gonna give it to you
you're gonna have to take it and along
the way you're gonna get things said to
you your feelings are gonna get
all this [ __ ] as long as you know you're
getting something out of this maybe not
today maybe not today but in a few weeks
that come it could be a year it could be
two years don't give up just keep
putting your [ __ ] head down and go
down I was so happy on the drive home
last night not because of my spot not
because of how I did because it Jason
Lucas because the formula works I don't
give a [ __ ] what they told you what they
didn't tell you the formula always works
and it has 4 mm [ __ ] years I didn't
write it and it will for 200,000 more
years after I'm [ __ ] dead Berryville
another planet so stick to it I see that
as always works also last week for the
schedule out that Josh boof wanted to
coma Washington two weekends ago and he
bumped into the old club manager at at
the Seattle underground the comedy
underground where I developed really as
a feature act I was there for two or
three years it's so weird that again
before Mitzi and Carl warm at home Carl
warm and Hagen was in charge of the open
mics on Monday and Tuesday and he would
make the list and if you look at the
list I put up I was like number four
maybe number five
that was my first open mic up there the
guy believed that he have it because I
had recurrent squalling my comics dear
friend of mine at Denver and he blew
smoke up his ass and he put me up for
the open mic and he put me at number
five by the time I left two years later
I always was closed no shows out like I
was the headliner on all those shows and
he guided me through that I was very
fortunate to have that time piece of him
because he guided me through that I
would go up there every Monday and
Tuesday and one thing I did was I gave
him the respect he deserved he took care
of me so I had to take care of him I did
the main thing that all those people
want to see I wrote I made a little bit
of progress every week from every Monday
and Tuesday I went in there and I know
to save two minutes from Monday and two
minutes for Tuesday that one new and I
remember switched him around I used to
say a joke back then but he used to got
a big kick
and he gave me a bunch of tags for
that's what he was well known for car
warming over when you got off the stage
he'd give you tags even at that level I
would never use him but I'd ride him
around and this those tags expanded your
mind
he made you think a different way and
I'm him after a year one night on a
Monday night or Tuesday he made me
follow Rick neukölln from the burbs
what's on the movie he did with [ __ ]
Tom Hanks with the [ __ ] what's the
m1a Groundhog Day with Bill Murray he
did that Rick duChemin was a brilliant
comic from Toronto Canada God rest his
soul
[ __ ] great guy and one night he
wanted to test my balls car woman home
but he didn't say that into me and say
none I got down in and what's going on
am I going up tonight yeah you following
Rick my holy [ __ ] is Rick
no I didn't even know who Rick was he
goes you're behind the next guy and
because he didn't show me the guy's belt
the second jujitsu are you gonna go
wrestle with a guy he's got a brown belt
you got a blue belt right away your
[ __ ] skunk goes up your tail goes up
and you get a little weaker or whatever
that is to make you tougher you know so
if somebody doesn't have a belt on and
you don't know what is ranking how are
you gonna go into it you ever think
about that so it's the same thing in
life if you don't know who this guy is
going on before you won't make you
nervous so he didn't tell me who it was
the guy destroyed the [ __ ] room was i
paranoid no because I thought he was no
open-mike I went up there and this is
1997 this is 23 years ago I went up
there and I didn't level the room but I
did Trant fantastic and when I got off
the stage I'm all my comedy guys like
Josh attained him anew with Brody
Stephens and [ __ ] chard Hogan they
all came up to me and they gave me a big
hug like you did great considering who
the [ __ ] you just followed and I'm like
cool a [ __ ] that I just followed me you
just followed the [ __ ] Rick Newcombe
and he's got an HBO special blah blah
blah blah blah and that in turn made me
Friends of Rick like once I started
looking at him close to I realized it
was a guy from
des and the guy from HBO and I formed an
immediate bond with the guy he gave me
his nominee told me if I was I would
coming to Hawaii to keep in touch with
him and he pretty much the first year I
was here he was one of my guides before
Rogan before Jimmy Schubert before Paul
Morley he was my guy he taught me how to
call it the spots at the store he gave
me a recommendation at the store with
Carlos Mencia Doug Stanhope I mean I
loved Rick you know it's a shame that he
passed away years ago he told me stories
that they wouldn't give him spots at the
improv so he would wait for the show to
be over and he'd bring his own little
spotlight and he would buy everybody a
drink at the bar and make him come in to
watch him just so he could build an
audience's before they had the lab this
before they had anything that was the
mind of Rick dukeman he also taught me
something really his wife told me a
story one time they had just had just
done David Letterman and they drove from
like New York there's the Letterman set
finished at 7:00 they drove from New
York all the way the way were the [ __ ]
they lived in Ohio not where they live
well my mother was from and they got in
the middle of the night Rick slept all
day ate dinner with them and after
dinner he was sitting at all his
father-in-law but he was putting his
sneakers on and his wife said to him
where you going
she goes I Drive here I saw it there's a
pizza place down the block and they're
doing an open mic night think I just did
let him in HBO specials she goes he's
other pizza place and I know they do an
open mic over there I'm gonna go over
and try some new jokes and she said to
him but you just did let him in last
night and he goes that's my point
I gotta start the [ __ ] next day so
all those little experiences for me and
those little ideals that were put in my
head will put now by Carl Waldman home
so maybe if he comes down to Iowa I'll
get him on the show he's still alive and
kicking just as he looks better than
ever and you guys saw the names on there
from Brodie through a - bullet - Josh
wolf the those are the [ __ ] days when
I used to sleep in my car I lived with a
stripper
you know we would
doing spot we were just [ __ ] kids and
then we are 24 [ __ ] years later so
the struggle never ends and that's what
Monday is all about to remind you that
the struggle never ends and you always
got another [ __ ] week to go right I
always want to thank you guys for
supporting us for last six years it's
always a [ __ ] pleasure happy is we've
become friends on the outside of this so
that's always [ __ ] great and I hope
that you get something from these
podcasts yeah I say some raunchy [ __ ]
from time to time and we cordially and
we do drugs but the heart of the podcast
the the whole reason to what would be is
say you guys get something out of it and
thank you very much I will be checking
in with you guys I will not have
Facebook on the road I do not ever bring
facebook on the road to do not Facebook
me know if you need to get ahold of me
twit me only just tweet at me tweet at
me leave me a [ __ ] Twitter message
and I'll get back to you is back as fast
as I can like I said I'll be on and off
with these [ __ ] films till May 17th
I'm not doing any comedy show us after
4:00 19th this tickets still available
for 4:20 in Milwaukee for the Early Show
a couple from the Late Show it's gonna
be a great show you know bring some reef
let's do some edibles that's heat some
xanax
let's heat some [ __ ] Viking him
whatever you got bringing just make sure
you bring some kombucha juice there's
other way your stomach to get sick mix
then like say you're [ __ ] crying to
me [ __ ] anyway a little word from
my [ __ ] sponsors as I told you
earlier even when I had the flu or
whatnot with the body aches I kept
taking my CBD and I tell you it helped
you understand me and I know you look at
me like Joey I I live in the state where
they sell CDs at stores I get calls all
the [ __ ] time I got emails all the
time listen it's a [ __ ] nightmare
finding a CBD that works for you it
really is thank God
I introduced you guys to CBB lion when I
read their [ __ ] pamphlet and what
they do with the testing I mean they
broke it down to what bad what kind of
color a strawberry call stuff like that
to smoke of this CBD blends to fix your
ailment that's what I knew these people
kid and lucky for you we got CBD line
because they make CBD products from
start to finish
CBD line and has you covered now it
comes in a variety of [ __ ] forms you
can get in a vape you get cartridges you
get shatter and if you're not into
smoking I'll tell you what the gummy
bears we got them here some Winley
there's only two of them and [ __ ]
your legs don't hurt no oh yeah all
right
all use the tension like me you just put
a couple drops under your tongue swish
it around let it go through your glance
and boom drink a little bit of water and
I'll tell you what the next day your
[ __ ] brand new you gotta step in this
you got some pep in your step and after
a while you're gonna feel a lot better
you're gonna go [ __ ] Joey I didn't
know they come in thousand milligrams
and a picture of five thousand
milligrams let me listen
CBD Lyon does that great of a job their
products are clean
Bobby and they aren't like the fakes
that with the fait with the false
advertising that you see all over the
place remember years ago what's that
black Chinese juice jinxing it was
selling at [ __ ] 7/11 next to the
wings if you buy that jinxing that they
put next to the wings at 7-eleven you
should go to [ __ ] hell on your
[ __ ] [ __ ] leave the [ __ ] life no
more that fake [ __ ] and that's what
they're gonna do with CBD thank God
uncle Joey got you CBD line so do me a
favor go to CBD line right now and
before you oughta do anything check out
the third party lab results yourself
read what they have to offer and pick
what suits you at CBD de Lyon calm all
right the church family gets 20% off at
checkout when you use the code Church
like a [ __ ] 20% so go to CBD
Lyon and change your life right now the
church is also brought to you by Robin
Hood Robin Hood is an investment that
lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options and Kryptos or Commission free
while the brokerage firms charge up to
$10 for every trade Robin Hood doesn't
charge any Commission feeds so you can
trade stocks and keep all the profits
yourself plus there's no account minimum
deposit needed to get started see
could start investing at any level
that's simple it's simple intuitive
design i'm robin hood makes investing
easy for newcomers and experts alike
view easy to understand charts and
market data and place a trade ready for
this one and just four taps on your
smartphone you can also view stop
collections such as the hundred most
popular with robin hood you can learn
how to invest in the market as you build
your portfolio that's the most important
thing you discover new to stocks track
your favorite companies and get custom
notifications for price movements so you
never miss the right moment to invest
robin hood is giving the church family
the listeners a free stock like apple
for the sprint to help you build your
portfolio sign up at church that robin
hood calm again
that's church dot robin hood dot-com the
church is also brought to you by zip
recruiter this is as good as it gets you
talk about how challenging hiring is
i'll find this to how hard it is to find
qualified candidates it takes too long
too many applicants
Oh zip recruiter makes it easy work in
the URL once at the beginning zip
recruiter doc Cobb slash Church hiring
is challenging but there's one place
where hiring a zip is simple and that
zip recruiter calm why the zipper cruda
the applicants analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
sends your job to over a hundred of the
web's leading job boards but they don't
stop there with the powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find the right people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job zip recruiter is so
effective you ready for this one that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a qualified candidate
to the site within the first day let me
repeat that again zip recruiter get out
of four out of five employees who post
on zip recruiter you get a quality
candidate through the site within
first day that's results that's saving
you time and that's saving you money and
aggravation and right now the listeners
the church family can try zip recruiter
for free gratis nothing it's tax day
Joey how else can you mess up my date no
zip recruit is free at zip recruited
cops last Church that zip recruited
dot-com [ __ ]
slash Church spelled CH you are CH
zipper gulab calm the smartest way to
hide again the next three weeks I'll be
on and off but you got your your podcast
coming to you baby all right I just want
to let you know what's going on today
can remind you it's Monday whatever
dream you had what everything you had
going on this is the [ __ ] week
you turn it around who gives a [ __ ]
about January 1st any [ __ ] can make a
[ __ ] wish and if he doesn't follow up
it goes back down the pizza dough you
got another chance to start right now
your tax a little refund not Trump took
away all your money [ __ ] [ __ ] this but
who gives a [ __ ] uncle Joey's here to
give your love give you motivation for
another week to go out there grease your
nutsack and sticking up somebody's culo
you understand me
don't forget Saturday night for 20 days
tickets left in the Pats Minneapolis is
sold out and that's it and that's that I
love you [ __ ] thank you for
supporting me I'm whether our months of
going on this one I'm Rogan where the
[ __ ] I am you're always there listen to
the past podcasts of Mike Tyson to
Ralphie made my man Brody Stephens we
got a more on the [ __ ] book theater
this is prior missus prior and that's it
and that's that I'll see you guys uh
Thursday I love you [ __ ] to
death and one Bing of applause for the
mayor of [ __ ] arch which my brother
the Christ killer the original mr. Lee
syat I love you [ __ ] have a
great week write your gold eat your
vitamins
coming your wife's I and get back at me
press to this [ __ ] have a great
week kicked this [ __ ] mealy